long ago in the wintry north an army of
demons emerged from beneath the icy
ground and spread darkness and despair
across the land astride their monstrous
spiders flanked by giants they wreaked
havoc on the innocent
slaughtering thousands all hope was lost
until the fearless warriors of the first
Night's Watch
drove them back into the wintry
mountains and built a magic wall to keep
them from ever invading again these
stalwart brothers in black continue to
protect us even to this day from the
evils that lurk in the shadows an absurd
lie a fairy tale spun by many a wet
nurse in the north to be sure a giant
wall does exist the triumph of
engineering perhaps but not of magic as
for the Nights Watch there may have been
a time centuries ago when there was
prestige and honor in the miserable
monastic life of a black brother but now
the wall has become a glorified penal
colony full of outcasts criminals and
assorted ne'er-do-wells today a typical
man of the Nights Watch most likely
started out a lowly beggar or a rapist
or a village idiot as for the few
highborn Watchmen
they either fought on the losing side of
a war or were disowned by their parents
for one reason or another those who
persist in defending the Nights Watch
will claim the Seven Kingdoms need
protection from the wildling tribes of
the far north but there's little to fear
from those primitives
there are nuisance but not sophisticated
or powerful enough to be a significant
threat to the realm and any talk of
White Walkers returning with their
armies of the Dead and their giant
spiders and their snarks is just that
talk